on va chez rim et ses manies faille que
ça ne va pas du tout du tout du tout du
tout
[Musique]
et là on se lançait un petit concours
d'imitation donc le pressoir et simple
ce petit machin envers bon marché de
dans des imitations tirent au hasard
je prends donc une imitation et je la
tribu valéry giscard d'estaing donc se
regarde et je me dis que thierry moreau
sera madame beauchemin mademoiselle
mouchoirs mouche a bien levé
je pense que les jeunes se régale il a
fait exactement la leur à feu de rachat
[Applaudissements]
lp passe à la fin mais j'ai trouvé mon
psy je sais pas en plus je les aime
tellement elle le sait est infiniment
ben ça c'est du pur plaisir
mettez nous la vraie quand même qu'on
voit si le mitage des mois
[Musique]
chose
comment manley mimant un art comme un
soldat comme une star de cinéma
oui mais il serait temps de s'intéresser
un petit peu au patrimoine de la chanson
française et c'est moi oui enfin elle
est belge donc nicolas sarkozy à
ségolène ait dit ce gars mais s'élève à
la maison
[Applaudissements]
antibes attendu dans le dos mais c'est
qu'il dit ça c'est quand j'ai mon str
il faut vraiment que j'aime monsieur ce
moon pour lui avoir laissé ma place
johnny hallyday a donné au lycée très
heureux ce soir
je tenterai pour l'émission c'est bien
et j'ai une vraie passion jean
reconnaître pour monsieur paul juste une
imitation foireuse mais c'est pour me
mettre dans l'ambiance quoi merde paris
c'est minable
le mouvement que des gens applaudissent
par christine eu autant de kalou c'est
que maintenant on va arrêter à chéri
mais c'est magnifique ça ne va pas du
tout du tout du tout du tout assuré
alors là tu es magnifique au magnifique
aubry tout sourire à julia elle a du
rhume
[Rires]
on va arrêter là la séquence va durer
longtemps non cotées c'était la dernière
mais moi j le faire un rhododendron et
bien je vous mets au défi de 0,2
[Musique]